alors parents de joe cole vous lui avait
consacré un livre avec l'achat auprès
memory jock of l'homme qui a vaincu
hitler chez perrin alors c'est l'homme
qui a vaincu hitler ou c'est l'homme qui
a sauvé staline schukoff c'est c'est une
question piège
évidemment il ya un petit peu
d'exagération dans ce titre il n'a pas
il n'est pas seul à avoir vaincu hitler
bien entendu c'est l'armée rouge c'est
11 millions de morts c'est le peuple
soviétique
c'est l'ensemble des alliés occidentaux
américains britanniques comme lyon pour
dizaines de milliers de pilotes anglo
saxons qui sont morts c'est grâce à la
marine aussi des anglo saxons que tout
ce petit monde est venu à bout d'hitler
s'était pas chose facile
j'ai dit que j'ai écrit que geof avaient
avait battu hitler parce que je pense
que à l'ouest on n'a pas été on n'a pas
été juste à son égard de même qu'à
l'armée qu'à l'égard de l'armée rouge au
général on avait su on a toujours vu que
les défauts et dieu sait qu'il y en
avait dans cette armée rouge mais on n'a
jamais vu les qualités et les produits
de très bonne qualité qu'elle a pu
sortir parmi lesquels des gens comme
joue kof
roh kossowski wasilewski malinowski
koniek call bookeen
en réalité ils sont nombreux j'ai fait
sortir je coche du lot parce qu'il est
le plus important pour les postes qu'il
a tenus et que dès 1941 il s'impose
comme le principal conseiller
d'installer mais il n'est pas seul loin
de là
[Musique]